l'été blinois 2021 et et sportif avec
les jeux olympiques de tokyo 11 athlètes
heavy nous ont participé à cet événement
planétaire mention spéciale aux trois
triathlètes de poissy qui remporte la
médaille de bronze tout comme
christopher 6 en équitation le
versailles et valentin porte en handball
et guillaume chaîne de sartrouville
remporte la médaille d'or les jeux tokyo
à peine refermées tous les regards sont
désormais tournés vers les jo de 2024 à
paris le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli en
septembre le passage du drapeau
olympique dans sa structure du cyclisme
également dans les yvelines avec le tour
de france la dernière étape est parti
depuis chatou taddei chpo gars de char
vainqueur de cette édition 2021 et
julian alaphilippe étaient présents sur
la ligne de départ
côté politique le conseil d'état a
tranché il faudra revoter pour les
élections municipales attrape le maire
élu en 2020 à l'irs avait été sanctionné
suite à des infractions pendant sa
campagne et date des nouvelles élections
les 10 et 17 octobre
de son côté valérie pécresse a annoncé
sa candidature pour les élections
présidentielles de 2022 l'ancien député
des yvelines venait d'être réélu pour un
second mandat à la tête de la région ile
de france depuis le 21 janvier il est
obligatoire de présenter un pass
sanitaires pour accéder aux lieux de
loisirs et de culture comme les musées
will cinéma les salles obscures ont
enregistré une chute de la fréquentation
de 70% le pass sanitaire devient
également obligatoire à partir du 9 août
pour aller manger au restaurant attrape
première étape pour le chantier de
l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 le
pont marcel cachin était démolie dans la
nuit du 17 au 18 août il surplombe et la
n 10 au niveau de la mairie le chantier
d'envergure devrait durer six ans en
septembre le musée départemental maurice
denis installé à saint germain les
rouvre ses portes après trois ans de
travaux le jardin et le bâtiment est et
restera une exposition inaugurale dédiée
à l'artiste peintre a été réalisé le
week-end des 11 et 12 septembre le
château de versailles écueil est la plus
grande reconstitution historique
d'époque 400 passionnés ont fait revivre
napoléon ce bicentenaire de l'empereur
l'électro également à l'honneur en ce
mois de septembre après une édition 2010
20 annulés en raison de la crise
sanitaire et des tricks pack de château
était de retour des milliers de fêtards
en participer à cette 11e édition sur
deux jours à thouars et un rhinocéros
blanc arrive au parc zoologique son nom
voit katy trois ans après la mort de
vince a battu en 2018 par des
braconniers pour récupérer sa corne
enfin il nous a quittés en ce début
septembre après une immense carrière au
cinéma jean paul belmondo alias bébel
est décédé à l'âge de 88 ans le comédien
avait passé une partie de son enfance à
clairefontaine en yvelines pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale